a new report about an investigation into
workplace culture at CBS News is raising
concern among some employees according
to the New York Times outside
investigators hired by the CBS board
uncovered reports of misconduct by some
60 Minutes employees that includes a
never before reported claim of sexual
assault against Don Hewitt the creator
of 60 minutes but The Times reports
investigators did not find a toxic work
or frat-house environment for women at
the wider news division a finding
disputed by multiple employees vladimir
duthiers our streaming network cbsn
shows us a concern blad good morning
good morning eight current female
employees tell us they have experienced
a toxic workplace or frat house
environment including harassment and
being made to feel uncomfortable a draft
report prepared for the CBS board
uncovered allegations of wrongdoing at
the top levels of the most successful
television news program in US history in
its 51 year history 60 minutes has been
run by just two executive producers Don
Hewitt and Jeff Fager both now
reportedly face misconduct allegations
reviewed by the New York Times rachel
Abrams from a leaked draft of a CBS
investigation it seemed like the
investigators were very very thorough we
know they interviewed hundreds of people
and their report included mixed results
according to The Times the report found
the success of 60 minutes allowed it to
operate separately from the rest of the
news division which led to misconduct by
some 60 Minutes employees in one
instance a former worker claimed Hewitt
sexually assaulted her on repeated
occasions and destroyed her career
CBS reportedly settled with the woman
for a total of five million dollars plus
75 thousand dollars a year for life
normally with a figure that big you
assume that the company has a reason to
believe that something very serious went
on Hewitt retired in 2004 and died five
years later Fager has also faced
allegations of sexual misconduct
including claims he groped one employee
investigators reportedly determined CBS
News was justified in firing him earlier
this year for sending a threatening text
message the CBS correspondent Jericka
Duncan and then allegedly lying
about it to investigators they also gave
credit where credit was due and credited
mr. faker with in some instances
promoting women Fager told the times of
the text quote my intent was only to
demand fairness and in response to the
report he said this is the first I'm
hearing some of these allegations I was
not given the opportunity by CBS
investigators to respond he later told
us this report shows 60 minutes is a
good place for women and the reports
that it isn't were exaggerated this
comes just days after the Times reported
on other allegations in the report
against former CBS chairman and CEO
Leslie Moonves who allegedly destroyed
evidence and deliberately lied about his
sexual misconduct the CBS Board will
have to decide if he's still entitled to
a 120 million dollar severance after
reading the final report there was a lot
of stuff in there there were a lot of
people mentioned in there I don't think
this is gonna be the last story about
the investigation we reached out to the
investigators as well as to spokespeople
for CBS and CBS News all declined to
comment in an email CBS president and
acting CEO Joe Aiello told employees it
was frustrating the report leaked to The
Times before management and the board
and knew about it he says while we still
don't yet know their actual results he
understands the investigation is nearing
an end you know what else is frustrating
that this period of reckoning I think
still continues for us and the fact that
this new reporting that eight current
female employees say that they have
experienced a toxic atmosphere means
that there's still more work to be done
here
and I for one I'm glad that that
investigation is going on I also hope
that when it's all done that we will
know exactly what happened here I don't
think we can move on until it comes out
let the chips fall where they may and
that we continue there are a lot of
talented people who are working here or
doing a really good job I'm very proud
to be part of the team but this is very
frustrating and you know I have to say
embarrassing mm-hmm I mean one of the
things we talked about more than a year
ago when this started was that not only
does this ruin people's lives but it
also drives women from the field of
journalism are working at CBS News which
is a great company and full of great
people but we want to make sure that
people not only feel safe here but they
are promoted in the right way that their
contributions are ignored
in the right sort of way so that we have
the best workforce out of any news
organization and transparency is key
throughout all of this invest our
calling card yeah yeah that's what sixty
minutes does transparency yeah yeah we
are glad thank you to you and the
producers that have done a lot of this
reporting we appreciate it